[Musique]
rien
[Applaudissements]
m
il y en ait le dos par les français se
sentent divisée comment vivez-vous le
problème de l'unité nationale il se
trouve que je suis à la fois du nord et
du sud mon père était fini ma mère et
gasconnes et j'ai l'impression de vivre
en moi cette unité et cette diversité de
la france et je crois que tous les
français sont plus ou moins comme moi de
terroirs différents d'origines
différentes
ce qu'ils ne veulent pas c'est
l'exclusion c'est l'inégalité mais ils
veulent bien la diversité et moi je veux
être un président de la diversité et de
l'unité de la france beaucoup de francis
en appréciant que la france se dilue en
europe
que leur répondez vous que je comprends
leur inquiétude
nous avons fait cette vieille nation à
travers les siècles nous ne voulons pas
qu'elle se défasse mais que je n'ai pas
leur crainte l'europe que je veux c'est
une europe qui donne sa force à la
france et c'est une europe aussi qui
défend les intérêts de ces peuples et sa
personnalité de ce que la france encore
quelque chose à lui dire au monde
on a les moyens de le faire nous sommes
la quatrième puissance économique
mondiale
nous sommes membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité nous avons ce rôle
central dans l'union européenne mais à
condition bien sûr de porter un message
la france n'est entendu que si elle a un
bep salle et valeur et notamment des
valeurs de progrès est élu président de
la république
c'est ce message que je veux incarner
jeu portrait avec force la voix de la
france
j'ai choisi il ne développe pas parce
qu'il est un âne est intègre et
courageux et qu'il a autour de lui une
équipe formidable de jeunes comme
martine aubry et comme dominique strauss
kahn comme elisabeth guigou et bien
d'autres mais ce que je dirais
aujourd'hui que je n'ai jamais dit
depuis bientôt treize ans qui nous a
quittés c'est que si pierre
mendès-france était là aujourd'hui il
appellerait à voter pour eux d'un jospin
depuis les universités médiévales le
savoir la recherche ont été une des
principales richesses de la france
plus que jamais aujourd'hui une nation
moderne a besoin pour ses citoyens pour
sa place en europe et dans le monde
d'une recherche qui soit une priorité
pour ses gouvernants
lionel jospin a été selon mon expérience
le ministre qui a le plus fait pour la
recherche universitaire en 1986 en 1993
la droite n'a pas eu les mêmes
motivations pour la recherche pour la
france une chance à fond
moi j'aime la france lorsqu'elle est
juste la république dans ce qu'elle
reconnaît tous ses enfants et en
particulier les jeunes
notre pays aujourd'hui subi une grave
crise sociale dues au chômage avec son
cortège de misère l'exclusion la
toxicomanie la violence la france a
besoin d'une politique forte pour
surmonter cette crise qui dure depuis
plus de 20 ans et en particulier elle a
besoin d'une réduction du temps de
travail
ilya dall jospin est le seul candidat
qui propose un programme adapté
ces propositions ne sont pas seulement
celle de la raison elles sont aussi
celles du coeur de plus lionel jospin
est authentique
il est issu du peuple et par ici de ce
mouvement de province la france est
notre oeuvre commune elle a surmonté la
crise ses capacités son dynamisme en
font une grande puissance mais le
chômage et l'exclusion met en cause sa
cohésion et beaucoup de français se
sentent rejetés la france que je bâtirai
avec vous sera plus forte plus juste et
plus fraternel elle sera davantage
ressembler plus solidaire nous serons
plus confiants dans l'avenir
nous retrouverons l'ambition la france
que je bâtirai avec vous plus unie à
l'intérieur affirme bras en europe et
dans le monde ces valeurs de paix de
liberté de démocratie et de
développement
[Musique]